what up
peeps i'm dave rubin this is the reuben
report direct message
for march 18 2021 and we are doing an
ask me anything
a question and answer session we got
over 200 questions at
reubenreport.locals.com that's where i
take questions no matter how many times
i tell the twitter people
i'm not taking questions here they keep
submitting questions but if you want me
to actually read your questions
and my team does read all of the
questions and then they tell me
what they think's best i quickly glance
through everything i don't prepare for
any of this it's coming right in front
of me i haven't even seen
fully all of them we just mix it up if
you want me to see them
you go to reubenport.locals.com and you
can submit your question we do the q a
every thursday so we're going to get to
as many as possible
i am going to cover one story today
because uh
obviously there was this shooting of the
massage parlor uh where six women
were killed uh well i guess it was seven
women
one man six of the women were asian i
mean even just
putting all of those attachments onto
everything like a life is a life is a
life but everyone is using this to sort
of fit their narrative right now
and jen pasaki who obviously is the
white house
spokeswoman uh you're not gonna believe
who she blamed yeah
orange man she blamed orange man so
we're going to talk about that and then
show you really a fantastic clip
to show you how ridiculous uh pasaki and
sort of the mainstream narrative is
uh before we get to that though i want
to talk to you guys about bonner private
wine
you know if you ever go out to a
barbecue joint and the next day you're
still digesting
all that meat we all know that feeling
here's a tip drink some red wine
not only does it taste great but red
wine actually makes you digest
meat more effectively this is a little
something i know about in fact according
to some studies it makes
red meat even healthier but not all red
wines are equal you don't want some mass
market red wine full of chemicals and
pesticides instead
you need to check out extreme altitude
malbec from australia i've got a bottle
of it right here
extreme altitude means grapes grown at
around 9000 feet
fed off pure snow melt no excess
chemicals with notes of blackberry
leather smoke and dark cherry this
wine is delicious actually we had a
really fantastic steak last night
i posted some pictures on my uh on my
instagram we knocked back a bottle of
this well two bottles
uh the guys over at freethinkerwine.com
are telling me they just got another
special shipment of these wines in
including
one from the third highest vineyard in
the world my audience can get 50
off if you go there today just go to
freethinkerwine.com that's
freethinkerwine.com
and now back to me all right so i want
to start by playing you this
clip this is yesterday this is white
house press secretary jen pasake
uh talking about the shooting that
happened again
i and every sane person on earth
absolutely condemn the shooting condemn
whatever the motive
may have been uh they're telling us that
the motive actually is because the
perpetrator this 21 year old kid
who happened to be white they're telling
us that he was a sex addict
and he was just going to these places
just to shoot up people
that's what that's what they're telling
us at the moment that's what law
enforcement is actually telling us
that's not stopping the narrative from
being spun that he was actually a white
supremacist
and somehow wanted to kill asian people
but listen to this
uh little moment at the press conference
from jen pasaki and then we're going to
play a little clip after that
in the oval office he didn't want to
make a connection on the motivation
in atlanta but to broaden it out why
does the president
think attacks on asian americans are
increasing in this country
why does he think that's happening well
he he wanted to be very clear because
there's an ongoing fbi investigation
right and he didn't want to attribute
motive there are law enforcement
authorities who do that
and it's important to note when uh when
the
uh when the investigation is concluded
or not so that was a bar he was attempt
working to respect there
um you know i think there's no question
that
uh some of the damaging rhetoric that we
saw
during the prior administration uh
blaming uh
you know calling covid uh you know the
wuhan virus or other things
um uh led to um you know
um perceptions of the asian-american
community that are inaccurate
unfair have raised um
you know threatening has elevated
threats against
asian americans and we're seeing that
around the country that's why even
before
the events of horrific events of last
night he felt it was important to
raise this issue elevate it during his
first prime time address
why he signed the executive order
earlier
in his presidency and he will continue
to look for ways to
elevate and talk about this issue man
she really is just terrible i mean talk
about an
inauthentic person who's just an
absolute bs artist and
and all of them at some level are that
right they're the filter
between the president and the media so
they have to their job is sort of
bs'ing right and that doesn't mean
they're all bad people dana parino who's
a good friend of mine who i just had
on the show a week or two ago uh she
talked she was the press secretary for
george w bush and she talks about some
of those
struggles and i think she's quite
upfront about it actually but jen pasaki
just comes off as deeply
deeply deeply inauthentic but what she
says there is there's no question that
some of the damning rhetoric from trump
has caused this well that's interesting
because trump called it the wuhan virus
or called it the china virus right
well hmm that's interesting so if those
words could lead to violence well then
you're not
jen you're not going to like this video
from mrctv
that i'm going to show you right now
concern
is growing this morning over an outbreak
of a new sars-like virus in china
at least six people have died from the
wuhan corona
virus the wuhan coronavirus the wuhan
coronavirus the 34-year-old
ophthalmologist diagnosed saturday with
the wuhan coronavirus
virus the wuhang coronavirus the wuhan
coronavirus what more can you tell us
about the similarities or differences
between
sars and the wuhan coronavirus the wuhan
coronavirus a wuhan coronavirus in china
the wuhan coronavirus the wuhang corona
virus from the wuhan
coronavirus wuhan coronavirus fears
continue to grow
over the outbreak of the wuhan
coronavirus wuhan coronavirus the wuhan
coronavirus
wuhan coronavirus we have new
information about how the wuhan
coronavirus is
[Music]
on man that's a lot of hate speech
being directed at you good people from
cnn and a couple other networks but cnn
went very heavy on that the
wuhan coronavirus and there's many other
videos by the way of mainstream media
people calling it the china virus
by the way for the record i have no
problem calling it the wuhan virus i
have no
problem calling it the china virus that
shouldn't make
any sane person be bigoted towards
chinese people
we do know that it came from wuhan china
that is just a fact
just to clarify one thing there were
nine victims in the shooting eight were
killed
six happen to be asian women now again
the shooter from everything that the fbi
is telling us at the moment
did not do this in the name of racism it
had something to do with his sex
addiction i'm guessing he maybe went to
some of these places and
who knows like we will all find that out
and by the way
if it is found out that it turns out
that he was in a whole bunch of white
supremacist
uh facebook groups or what wherever
these people coordinate probably reddit
or some of the more evil underbelly
internet sites
it's like then of course you we would
talk about that like obviously i would
cover that and i'm completely against
white supremacy
i'm against black supremacy and i'm
against asian supremacy and
all other kinds of supremacy but the
point is that when posaki blames this on
trump look i went to a lot of trump
rallies as you know there were plenty of
asian people there i never
saw anyone bigoted towards asian people
if you want to talk about
who is actually being bigoted and racist
towards asian people in society in 2021
how about harvard that has quotas that
eliminate asians
from getting to harvard that make you
you have to score higher as an asian and
there's still a good chance you're not
going to get in because there were too
many asians at harvard
at the great liberal institution of
harvard we know
that as critical race theory and the
rest of this nonsense leaks into all of
our
institutions and into our giant
corporations who is it going to
discriminate against
it's going to discriminate discriminate
mostly against
asians jews too indians too
any minority group that succeeds that
actually mangles the calculation in the
intersectional calculator right that's
against what the left needs they need
their victims to be victims otherwise
the whole narrative falls apart
asians in america have not been victims
by any imagination
have has there been anti-asian violence
has there been anti-asian bigotry
has there been discrimination like there
is against every group has there been
irish discrimination saint patrick's day
was yesterday has there been
discrimination against italian people
and and virtually everybody
yes and what it is your job to do is
overcome that and become a thriving
member of society which
which asian people have probably done
better
than any group of people if you care
about groups people all right we got a
zillion questions we're going to get to
them but real quick guys bill
barr let's talk about it not bill barr
talking about bill barr
it's not often that you get to put that
you get to put the words healthy and
delicious in the same sentence together
so if you've been struggling to keep
that new year's resolution to get
healthier i'm about to bring you some
really good news it's called
built bar and it's the rare item of food
that's both healthy
and delicious i've got several bars
right here
they are high in protein and fiber low
in calories and carbs each bar contains
110 to 160 calories up to 20 grams of
protein
and only three to five net carbs you can
do this on keto if you want
and meanwhile it's made with real
chocolate and tastes amazing this is the
kind of snack that's going to allow you
to lose or maintain weight while
indulging in something delicious
and that's always a welcome change built
bar has a ton of amazing flavors like
caramel brownie
cookies and cream peanut butter mint
brownie and a lot more don't give up on
your
resolution built bar is the answer go to
builtbar.com
and use promo code ruben to get 15 off
your next order use promo code ruben and
you'll get 15 off at billbar.com and now
back to me
all right let's plow into the q a i
promise i'm going to do as many as
possible we got we got about 200
they selected some i quickly glanced at
a few of them but not even all of them
and away we go truman says are you
seeing any shifts
in the idw types under a biden
administration
as in are they starting to wake up i
know it's been frustrating to see many
of them lag behind in terms of
understanding the gravity
of what we're facing uh you know i get a
lot of questions like this when people
come up to me on the street they ask me
like what's going on with the idw crew
it seems like a whole bunch of them have
sort of gone off the deep end or
disappeared or anything else
so i will say this let's let's remove
two of the people
from it let's remove ben because ben
shapiro uh he's been as outspoken
as ever obviously daley wire is crushing
it across the board
candace owens new talk show which i'm
going to do in in nashville in the next
couple weeks i think it debuts today
even is it today or maybe even
maybe tomorrow i'm being told tomorrow
okay so they're just crushing over there
and ben is outspoken on absolutely
everything as always
so that's ben and then i would say you
have to sort of remove jordan peterson
from the equation
because obviously with the health stuff
that he went through for the last year
and a half almost two years actually
he just wasn't chiming in on a lot of
things he's just getting back the book
just came out
i know a lot of you saw my my two hour
interview with him so he's going to
start
uh being more outspoken obviously as he
gets his health in order actually just
this morning i saw him tweet about
uh how bill c-16 that he was warning
about way back when
and people said he was a racist white
supremacist because he didn't want the
government of canada to compel speech
in relation to what pronouns you use to
trans people uh
he's now seeing that that is just
bursting forth into into so many other
uh parts of society i would say um look
if you if you took someone like sam
harris the truth is
he when trump got booted off twitter and
youtube and facebook and
pinterest and everything else sam
literally tagged at
jack the ceo of twitter jack dorsey and
thanked him
for for banning donald trump like you
know
so you can make your own judgment call
on that you know
i i tweeted something to sam about in
effect like you know
i'll i'll still defend you but i'll
probably get booted before you take
they take you out because obviously a
lot of people are thrilled with him so i
think he sort of removed himself
uh from a way but i would say in a
bigger sense like the weinstein brothers
joe rogan barry weiss like whole crew
like are these people
for lockdowns or not i don't really hear
anyone talking about the things that i
think
are the most important things out there
i know everyone's doing their things
that's not even really a judgment call
on anyone
specifically and it sounds like i'll be
doing eric weinstein's podcast in a
couple weeks and i'd be happy to hash
out any of these
issues publicly but i would say the
lockdowns and the the response to kovid
has been the most important issue of the
day on top of censorship and everything
else and if you're just seeing people
not really addressing those things
um then it's up to you to decide whether
they're they're an important
you know public person for you to follow
or not and i would include myself in
that like if you think i'm not doing
a great job or i'm you know denying some
of the realities of what's going on here
but i do think what in essence happened
is that the trump thing sort of broke
people in a certain way like it became
obvious to me that trump was sort of the
last guy
guarding guarding the gate and we've
talked about this before
and and i said okay i've got to support
the guy for that reason for whatever his
flaws are
and i think a lot of the people that
that didn't support him or or maybe
uh privately did but but didn't want to
do it publicly
i think the rubber has now met the road
where it's so obvious that biden
with dementia and the energy of the
crazy left behind him is destroying all
of the very things that the
you know quote-unquote good liberals
stand for so it's put them in
a unenviable position i would say uh i
said i was going to do these quick that
was not quick i'll see what i can do
here here's patriot girl two
she says what's your take on john
kerry's maskless flight
think america airline will do anything
my guess is america airlines not going
to do anything i suppose it was nice to
see john kerry
fly commercial because you may remember
a couple weeks ago he was talking about
how he
has to fly around the world private to
tell everybody about climate change
because that's really uh that's a real
green way of
of doing your travels right john so to
just see him on a commercial plane like
one of the peons one of us is nice
john kerry i mean i always find the
funny part about this is you know he
married into big ketchup money you know
that
he married teresa hines and she's you
know the heinz ketchup
so he's got all the ketchup money he's
flying uh
you know regular class that's i guess
regular class he's he might have been in
first class i'm not sure but he's fine
commercial at least um
but yes if you don't know what i'm
talking about yesterday he was
photographed on a flight
an american airlines fight without a
mask it did not appear that he was
eating or drinking
this is what they do guys they they just
want you to live
like robots under their control and they
and if you think that john kerry doesn't
have parties at his house and if you
think they don't have get-togethers
and that they they i mean the guy's
worth hundreds of millions if he doesn't
have staff around him
they they want to be treated great while
you are completely controlled and
neutered and everything else i don't
think american airlines will do anything
although when i flew back
from florida a couple weeks ago they did
announce on my
american airlines flight that if you're
eating peanuts on the plane you should
eat them
with rather rapidly you know because
otherwise they'll
be watching you you can't just slowly
take a peanut and think about life
and then take another peanut so you know
i guess i could have been kicked
off that plane i wasn't uh first of all
i also thought peanuts weren't even
allowed on planes anymore but
uh a trittenbach says this week
the infallible fouchy the second
greatest doctor only to jill biden
talked about the real possibility of the
next pandemic and today
do you think they are conditioning us
for the next pandemic and new lockdowns
i do
i do i don't think that's a crazy
conspiratorial thing to say
i think when you say they i mean that's
where we get sort of lost in it like
what is they is that just the system is
there
i don't think it's necessarily a cadre a
secret cadre of people
that sit and and plot all these things
but i think the system itself
saw that wow we can shut down
the world destroy businesses destroy
lives get all of these people to put
masks on
in a second mask and put gloves on and
we can also figure out how their
shopping habits
change and figure out that they'll do
more online and that they'll keep buying
more and more movies on apple tv
and not go out and like all of the
economic stuff that somebody's making
money
off of all this stuff right jeff bezos
ain't that pissed about lockdowns i'm
not saying he's forcing the lockdowns
but i think you get my point so i think
they the system tested us
and i think for the most part we failed
you know some some people did not fail
i would say um you know ron desantis in
florida did not fail
and then by him being brave and doing
the right thing the millions of people
that he governs i think got a little
extra
bit of bravery but i'm here in los
angeles and there ain't a whole lot of
brave people although i do occasionally
have dinner with some of them and again
that's just satire i would never have
someone for dinner
last night and post a picture about it
on my instagram today no i wouldn't have
done that
uh amber says what do you think about
the department of defense's war on
tucker carlson
is it foreshadowing totalitarianism or
just an emotional reaction
of the woke in the ranks so without
getting too deep into the story the dod
has
had a couple twitter accounts you know
blue check twitter accounts go after
tucker
tucker did a segment a few days ago
about pregnant women in the military
i don't want to sound like a crazy
reactionary here but frankly if a woman
is pregnant
i i wouldn't want her on the front lines
of a war uh you know that that's just me
but
not because she couldn't do it uh but
you know there might be some health
stuff there for the baby you know
just would be something but watching
actually the system go after tucker so
it's a little bit different when you see
like governmental twitter accounts right
official government
sanctioned twitter accounts go after a
private member of society rather than
just like the losers at media matters
who are watching this
or like the irrelevant dingbats at you
know
daily beast or all the people that are
just trying to constantly cancel us
so i do think it's an escalation of a
certain sort but tucker hasn't been
scared away yet and his ratings are
killing it and he's doing good work so i
think he's going to be just fine
t-rex says i just started working for a
company that's evidently very woke
hiring based on immutable
characteristics etc do you have any
recommendations for how a lowly employee
could try to steer the ship in the right
direction from the inside
you know i would say it's almost
impossible because once the infection is
there
um it basically takes over the host
that's why i always compare it to alien
right it's like it gets in you it
gestates and then it bursts forth when
it doesn't need that body anymore
so there's probably not that much you
can do but i would say this
detail everything going on there every
instance where you see someone being
hired because of skin color
or or you know a white person doesn't
get a promotion just because he's white
or whatever
the craziness that you're seeing in
there certain people treated certain
ways because of their sexuality or any
of that
stuff done in the name of tolerance even
though it's really the most intolerant
set of ideas possible keep records of
all of that stuff and by the way it's
not that you're going to take that to hr
and hr is going to do anything because
we know that the hr
departments in many of these companies
is completely corrupted but at some
point if you get passed over
for a job or something happens to you
well then
maybe you have a lawsuit maybe you can
go to some of the people that are
fighting this on the outside i would say
follow chris ruffo
on on twitter because he's doing a great
job and he's leading a whole bunch of
lawyers fighting this at many different
levels
excuse me for one moment
because sometimes people say dave you
seem a little parched when you're on the
show you're talking a lot you seem a
little parched stop and and have a drink
so there it is all right although i'm
drinking coffee which i think parches
you in a certain way
uh david says i'm an elementary school
principal in dare i say
public school but i have to come i've
come to realize that at least
i at least have some power to positively
influence my students in my school
what are one or two things that you
think i ought to discuss
or that i ought to focus on in order to
fight off the ever creeping far left
agenda
look this is tough because if if you
fight it then you'll be
you know i mean you know what they're
going to do right they're going to tell
you you're racist you're far right all
of those things you'll have a mob come
after you and all that
i would say maybe try to do something a
little softer which is just
whenever you're talking to these kids
just keep pushing the idea that hey guys
you know you can think for yourselves
we don't know everything the subtitle in
my book thinking for yourself in the age
of unreason
it's like you can think for yourself and
i think young people don't realize that
young people are being taught to conform
that's why seeing all these young kids
with masks
all over the place like everything is
being taught to conform and the system
you have to bow to the system like
there's nothing cool anymore
you know remember punk rock remember
when like you know
the the anything someone i saw this
morning that james lindsay tweeted
something they're trying to cancel
greece now because of misogyny and it's
like
john travolta in greece he was the cool
guy not because because he wasn't like
the guy that was part of the machine
right
you know that's what the whole movie is
about at frankie valley
greece is like one of the greatest songs
of all time but i would say just
keep pushing the idea that they can
think for themselves that you don't have
all the answers that the adults don't
have all the answers
that they can actually think and come up
to with conclusions themselves
uh kelly says as you transformed your
views how did that affect your
relationship with your husband
did you take the transformation together
i love this question um you know i
believe it or not
so david's a little younger than me and
he asks if you don't know this we both
are named david
i go by dave he goes by david it's wild
people can't believe it it's crazy
um but he's a little younger than me and
when he was really waking up to some
stuff about economics
like as we started making more money and
things were moving along and he's
looking at taxes and all that
i and this is still when i was a lefty i
kept saying to him you know you're
you're a scary republican you're a
conservative you
oh my god and i think he sort of moved
on that
first but you know we really do have
we've been together for
over 10 years at this point and we do
really have a very open honest
relationship and
and he's not that political he sort of
became political uh
as he was producing the show which now
he's stepping away from and
working you know we have several
businesses now so he sort of oversees
all that stuff
but he never loved the political part of
it um
so you know what's interesting is like
when we have dinner parties
hypothetically if we were to ever have
dinner parties at our house here
in los angeles um again really
hypothetically people these are not
things that really happen
um you know most of my friends are in
the political world obviously most of
our
our dinners our talks our chats all of
those things become about politics
but i would say he's mostly a
libertarian he's just kind of live and
let live he's not obsessed by all of
this stuff
um and if what he really loves is is
food and cooking more than anything else
which is why i post a lot of
food cooking pictures actually you can
go to his website davidscookbook.com and
see a lot of the stuff that i'm eating
uh candice says i'm going to miss live
comedy shows i'm curious who's your
favorite current stand-up comic
i don't know if there's anyone that i
really like right now i mean i haven't
been to a live stand-up show
in obviously over a year uh i believe i
have a week's worth of shows i think
we're gonna do about five shows in april
all in florida i'm just gonna bounce
around florida
uh sometime in april we're waiting on
the official dates on that
and basically i'm just i'm gonna do this
i'm just going to get on stage
you know i'll have a couple lines but
i'm going to mess with you guys crowd
work maybe i'll bring people on stage
we'll give stuff away we're just going
to be human beings laughing in a room
and drinking highly you know right wing
racist stuff so i look forward to
getting out there
in the florida uh laura says what advice
would you give people who want to build
a stable healthy life and relationships
for themselves but didn't have good
examples of these things growing up
i love this question because this is a
version of a question i heard all the
time when i was moderating the q and a's
while on tour with jordan peterson that
a lot of people like you could see they
were like getting themselves in order
but either their parents were messed up
or maybe the parents were out of the
picture or they just
did not have good role models um jordan
would answer
it with something like and i'm not going
to do it in in full jordan terms with
all the hand motions and everything else
but jordan would do it in some with
something to the effect of
you know you know that best version of
you like it's
it's in there somewhere we all know it
right and we know when we're living up
to that person or being that person
and then we know all the versions of
ourselves when we're not when we're not
being as honest we're not being as hard
working we're not being as generous or
as good or whatever that might be
and if you can really try to see that
and always keep an eye on that
that's sort of the star in the distance
that you gotta you gotta work for but i
would also say
and and this is uh what chapter nine in
my book is about
and don't burn this book is about find a
role model and for me jordan became that
sort of accidentally it wasn't like we
sat down like
you know find a role model or find a
mentor is really what the chapter's
about
and i think if you can find a mentor
meaning someone who's done a little bit
more than you
or maybe a lot more than you but you go
oh that's the type of person i would
want to be that
that person has accomplished the type of
things that i want to accomplish
um if you can find that and it doesn't
mean you're going to get to go on tour
with that person for a year but whatever
that is you know whatever that is if you
work
if you work wherever you're a car
mechanic like find the car mechanic
who who's lived a good life who's good
at what they do who's
accomplished and decent and they will
help you be better at what you want to
do as well
all right cooper says suppose all the
blue states secede when you move to the
red states yes
absolutely 100 without question i don't
even
need to extrapolate on this too much i'm
fighting
to save california for now you guys know
my feelings about
gavin newsom and the recall my hope is
we will get something that pushes back
on some of this stuff maybe we can also
recall our d.a here
the d.a in san francisco maybe we could
start the pushback
if if it all fails i'm leaving like you
know i think i gave it the old
college try you know like nobody's going
oh dave ruben didn't
try to do anything to fix that state the
inherent problem with that
and by the way i talked about a little
bit about this with in my interview with
rand paul senator rand paul which went
up this morning on youtube you guys can
check that out
is that you know if all of the good
decent freedom-loving liberty-loving
people in the blue states move to the
red states
well then what is the union at that
point now the counter to that would be
hey that's what federalism is that
people just move to all of these states
and live very different lives but i
think we would have such a national
cohesion problem which will already have
it happening at some level right if you
live in florida
you are living under a very different
set of circumstances and different set
of rules than you live under california
at some point the cohesion part of that
could become a massive problem and i
don't know if you've heard about this
but social media ain't helping
but yes i would move to a red state in
two freaking seconds
uh eileen says movie night i think
people could use a good laugh after this
insane lockup yes
we've done a bunch of movie nights uh at
reubenreport.locals.com where we all
pull up at netflix movie there's a
netflix party app so we can chat
live after and then we do a live video
zoom with 100
plus people um we actually maxed out at
100 last time so we have to upgrade the
account or something to
to get some more but we will do a movie
night soon
um i promise uh kelsey says
stuck on a desert island you have to
choose one of your least favorite
political figures
and one of your favorites who and why
well my least favorite obviously is aoc
i mean i think she has no concept of
what she's talking about i think she's
imported
an absolutely terrible set of what i
believe to be truly racist
ideas she loves collectivism she loves
big government
um she doesn't really know how to do
anything other than stay
liked in the media i suppose i think if
i was on an island with her it's not
like this is someone who could
actually help in any way what what could
she do what could she build i mean she
could complain
she could complain a lot and demand
fifteen dollars an hour for the work
that she doesn't know how to do
are you building the hut i want 15 an
hour i'll go we don't have any money and
we're on a we're on an island like lady
come on now
um so i wouldn't want to be with her but
you asked for my least favorite
my my favorite i mean look i just had
rand paul on today
so again check it out on on the youtube
over there
uh but i i like the guy i mean i really
like i think we could you know even if
even if it was the end even if it was
you know tom hanks and we're going down
it's like i think we would enjoy the
chats i think we would have good talks
about liberty and freedom and
the individual and things of that nature
uh gina says what makes you
really belly laugh uh i've mentioned
this a couple times i think
naked gun 1989 leslie nielsen naked gun
by the zucker brothers is the best
comedy of all time i remember
seeing that i was 12 or 13 years old i
remember seeing that in the movie
theater and i was in an aisle seat
and there was a big fat man sitting in
front of me and he fell
out of his chair laughing a big fat
man like 300 400 pounds plopped into the
aisle laughing i remember
belly laughing that pain that amazing
pain
when you just can't your body's like in
revulsion
because you are laughing so hard to me
and a lot of people will say but dave
airplane is better than naked gun
i am not a believer in that because to
me although the zucker brothers did
airplane too naked gun
like perfected that version of slapstick
over the top smack you in the head
comedy also
you know leslie nielsen of course he was
an airplane as well as the doctor but
like
he's just like the perfect comic actor
like straight faced absolutely perfect
ricardo montelva ricardo montebond is in
it
uh just a great great it's just nice
beaver like it's just the perfect movie
uh allison says if you run
for governor of california to replace
newsome will you hire a black woman to
replace
you as host on the reuben report looking
for a yes or no
if her last name's reuben you find me a
black woman
who already has the last name ruben
spelled the exact same way as me so i'm
sorry jennifer rubin you can't get in
and there's a couple other
there's a couple other pretty lefty
annoying rubens that are blue checkers
on twitter
you find me a black female reuben and
you got the show lady
uh landon says do you ever feel like
you're preaching to the choir and either
not reaching those
on the other side or actually push them
away great question i'm happy to answer
this
i would say generally no and and the
reason i know that is when i go out and
i do meet and greets and i meet people
on the street
people say hi to me at the store
whatever it is most people say
uh and most of my original audience like
when the show started
they were sort of disaffected liberals
right so they were the they were the
lefties who kind of woke up the red pill
lefties
and now i would say obviously a huge
chunk of my audience and for all i know
maybe it's over 50
is now i would say sort of more
traditional conservatives who happen to
be open-minded and
willing to agree to disagree that's a
pretty wide swath of people and i
and as i always say i mean i think that
is what the future of america is if
we're to remain a free country which
obviously is a big if
but if you take all of the disaffected
liberals and you take
the conservatives and you combine those
people together that's probably 80
of the country and then we can argue
about marginal tax rates and we can even
argue about abortion and some other
things but if the
basic premise of that huge group of
people
is in effect that america is pretty
decent and let's
let's see how we can keep making it more
decent rather than destroy the thing i
think that's pretty much everybody
as for the push them away part um i hope
that i don't
you know my behavior on twitter is
probably a little more well certainly a
little more combative than my behavior
is here and every now and again i do
drop the f-bomb here and that sort of
thing
i try to do this you know mostly with
some level of humor and a smile on my
face so that so that people
do feel welcome to this and that you
know if you send one of these videos to
a friend or a family member they're
gonna watch me and go oh that guy
doesn't seem like a complete partisan
maniac or just like a real prick
so i try to make it as welcoming as
possible for many people but
but i suppose if i i suppose at some
level i've pushed somebody away well
look i know that
my my say further left audience that i
started with they don't really like me
anymore but
you know you can't be liked by all the
people like i i wake up in the morning i
try to do what i think is right and then
you kind of go from there
amelia says you inspired me also to hop
off social media and i don't regret it
one bit
however i can say that there are some
things that i like like seeing my
friends and family's lives progress
through pictures and stories
is there anything you miss about social
media when you had it so to be clear
she is obviously amelia you're obviously
on locals which is awesome and one of
the things that i try to do in my
community
is not post a gajillion times a day you
know we post a clip or two a day i post
personally
maybe two three times a day and then
other members in the community are
posting but i'm trying not to bludgeon
everyone so that we're not all staring
at our phones
but i do have a ton of people in the
community who have told me that they now
because
of of our community on locals are now
off facebook they're off twitter
they're off all this stuff which i think
is spectacular as for the
the missing the good stuff right because
seeing the family pictures and the
stories and seeing relatives that are
having birthdays and all that kind of
stuff like that
is the missing piece and and by the way
we're working on some things over the
next little bit with locals that i think
will expand
on some of the good parts of social
media i don't miss it at all so like i
don't do
my instagram i don't i haven't been on
facebook in years like we have accounts
for the show
i do my own twitter um but even on that
like
i try not to look at responses really
because it's just because
for even if 90 of my responses are good
one the amount of just annoying like
hateful vile people on there is just
crazy so we've built something really
nice at locals and i i hope uh
i hope you're enjoying it so it's
reubenreport.locals.com if you haven't
sally from the valley says you've said
bill maher was one of your favorite
comedians back in the day mine too
now that he's speaking out a bit have
you asked him to be on the show we have
reached out a couple of times haven't
heard back i was supposed to be on for
my book
which when we got booked for the book
which was i was going to be on my book
came out april 28th i think i was going
to be on the week after
i said to my guys i was like i just have
a feeling they're going to cancel on us
and then covet happened they changed how
they were doing the show and everything
they canceled on us
then they did reach out to us a couple
months ago about maybe coming back on
and then it sort of went nowhere
i mean look bill maher back in the day
especially when i was more on the left
side of things i absolutely loved i do
believe him to be a good liberal
but i think he's at the end of his road
of liberalism and i think this is what's
happening to all of the good liberals
and bill maher
or real-time people because i know a lot
of employees and writers and producers
at real time watch this show
and keep having a lot of my guests on
and all that kind of stuff which is just
fine with me i'm happy that these people
are getting out there
bill is at the end of liberalism and at
the end of liberalism
you don't know what you're screaming
about anymore so bill maher will have
you know people like adam schiff on and
he'll complain that all his friends are
leaving los angeles because of high
taxes but then bill maher will vote
for people like adam schiff and adam
schiff if we play the clip here
adam schiff will say him oh we're
business friendly here in california and
it's like
and bill just sits there and it's like
no you're not you raise taxes on
everybody you have high regulation
everyone wants to get out of here you
have high income taxes and where do they
go they go
they go to texas why did joe rogan leave
california he signed a 100 million
dollar deal and then decided
that he didn't want to pay all the taxes
for it in california i don't blame him
for that so he went to texas
so bill maher i think has sort of you
know the trump thing i think
disregulated him the way it dysregulated
a lot of the liberals and by the way
with mar i'll give him a little bit of
an extra leash
because trump did go after him
personally i think they were talking
about suing each other at some point
but i would say in effect bill maher is
really he's an old-school liberal
but basically a libertarian he wants to
smoke pot
you know hang out with chicks he doesn't
like religion like he just wants the
government out of his life but he always
votes for democracy somehow still thinks
that democrats and lefties are better
than the people who want to live him
alone leave him alone and i think most
republicans most conservatives that's
all they want just leave me alone i
can't solve all your problems through
the government
so i think he's at the end of liberalism
which is probably why they haven't had
me on the show because i would
expose that like bill maher is supposed
to be sitting where i am
doesn't mean you're a card-carrying
member of the republican party i don't
consider myself
a republican but nine out of ten times
is the republican choice in 2021 going
to be better than the democrat choice of
course
but i don't even care about political
parties you know i care about i care
about ideas so is the conservative
say libertarian set of ideas way better
than the
the discombobulated authoritarian set of
ideas that's coming out of the left
these days yeah bill you want to talk
about it here
there wherever man i'll meet you i'll
meet you at the playboy mansion whatever
you want to do
uh all right part two of my interview
with david sacks
uh former ceo of paypal and just a guy
who gets it at the tech level and the
government level and everything else
is up on youtube right now and the full
episode is already up
ad free at reubenreport.locals.com my
interview with rand paul
came out this morning you can see it
right here on youtube and tomorrow we're
doing just like a weekly
news recap sort of the craziness of the
week
we already selected like 10 of the
craziest things and i've got uh lauren
chen
i've got richard mcginnis from the daily
caller and sarah gonzalez from the blaze
and if you want to chat with me say hi
see what i'm eating show me what you're
eating what you're drinking show me
pictures of your dog and all that good
stuff
check out reubenreport.locals.com i
thank you guys for submitting questions
and if we didn't get to you this week
we'll do it again next thursday and i'll
see you tomorrow